today jen sackey was asked about kyle
rittenhouse and whether or not joe biden
would apologize for implying in a video
that he was a white supremacist and jen
sackey was basically like what do you
mean he took pictures of the proud boys
right and all of a sudden i see across
twitter people being like well that's
securing a defamation lawsuit because
it's not true
but you know the problem is white
supremacist is an opinion so we will see
if kyle actually ends up filing a
defamation a lawsuit now interestingly
in his interview with tucker carlson he
said the phrase actual malice which is a
legal phrase
which implies young mr retinas has been
talking with some lawyers about what mr
biden mr president biden said
and it seems entirely possible so we'll
definitely get into that we also have
the written house precedent which is
triggering a bunch of left-wing
activists they're freaking out
and the funny thing is
there's no real precedent self-defense
has always been a privilege an
affirmative defense if you you know kill
somebody heaven forbid and now they're
surprised why well these rioters got
away with it for too long i mean for
nearly a decade i've watched these
extremists go through the streets
smashing and destroying and becoming
emboldened and finally now they're
actually worried that people are gonna
go out and defend their communities and
i gotta be honest i think there's a
reasonable fear that people might go out
we don't want active conflict in that
regard
and then of course we have the economy
which is in very serious trouble we're
being told not to buy turkeys we're also
simultaneously being told there's no
turkey shortage there is a turkey
shortage and maybe try tofurkey instead
you know what the st louis fed says
tofurkey's cheaper try the soy-based
garbage instead now i think americans
not being able to get turkey is going to
be a big wake-up call for a lot of
people about what's happening with the
biden government and the economy and
we've got one of the best people
imaginable to actually talk to us about
this we got peter navarro you want to
introduce yourself tim my friend before
i do that let me just salute you and uh
look uh as we talk about the news today
if there's a diaspora out there of folks
like you
um who
basically are speaking truth to power
and the dissonance between
what the american people are being fed
on the msnbc's and cnns and jenn sakes
is this world
versus the reality that
folks like you are bringing
uh to the table are really important and
and one of the ways i found myself here
today tim is through
a friend mutual friend jack the sober
right you know
he's like doing doing really good things
about at human events and one of the one
of the things that you know i listened
to is his podcast in the morning when
i'm kind of
working out a little bit at the
beginning of the day and
and
you know it's listen to boso big it's
like we find out uh things like the
victims right or not boy scouts right we
find out that the in the red house case
yeah in the rittenhouse case we find out
that
uh the the mayor the d.a
um
and
the lead detective are part of a family
that seemed to be
consciously trying to
shape the trial in a way which is
contrary to the facts we find out that
there's doctored videos that were
doctored in a way to make written house
look like he would lose his self defense
thing and the
so
then you see
then you see biden or sake saying things
like they're saying
and
we're at a point now uh and i've been
around a while got a few miles on me
we're at a point out i've never seen
before it's a total breakdown of the
mainstream corporate fourth estate
there's no truth to be had anymore
uh and the american people aren't buying
a lot of that
if you look at the polling the polling
um is is totally
inconsistent with the narratives of the
fake news so that means they're
listening to the folks like tim poole or
jack posobic or a place i live a lot at
uh steve bannon's war room as a as a
co-host
um and so i'm i'm happy to be here with
you tonight absolutely tim and uh so
does jam well who are you who am i
so um
uh
first and foremost since since i i want
to plug the heck out of this thing i'm
the author of this new book called in
trump time yes um the the title itself
is something that i coined
during my service in the trump
administration i was one of only three
senior officials in the trump
administration who was with the
president all the way from the 2016
campaign
where i was the top economic and trade
advisor all the way to the end of what i
like to refer to as his first term
um so so the in trumptime phrase
was became essentially the ethos and
culture
of the administration something i came
up early on in the iconic situation room
sitting around with a bunch of these
deep administrative state bureaucrats
i'm trying to on behalf of the president
move a trade policy and all on getting
his pushback and and finally it was like
no no no no no we're doing this in trump
time which is to say as soon as possible
and you come back tomorrow with a plan
to get this done in a week not in six
months and
if that doesn't work for you we'd be
happy to send you out to bethesda to
count paper clips in a warehouse this is
like this is what we do so and that that
became
that became like our and it really
became important
because i went from
the the the china hawk in the
administration the guy who was a lot
behind the steel and aluminum tariffs
the china tariffs i ran the whole buy
american hire american program i did
like a dozen executive orders for the
president and then suddenly it flips in
january 2020 and i turned into like the
quartermaster
uh for the pandemic trying to figure out
how to get enough ppe and that's the
subtitle of the in trump time book it's
uh my journal of america's play gear
what i did was like it was really
interesting tim when
when i got to the white house
early on
the biggest shock to me and it was truly
a shock
was that i faced as much opposition
inside the white house perimeter from
officials
who were trying to stop the president
from doing the two
transformational aspects of his agenda
which were was the secure borders and
the fair trade policies
and so
um what i did was i began keeping a
daily journal every night when i went
home no matter how tired i was i did i i
recorded the notes for the day and i did
it not just because i thought it might
be part of
history some small or large way but but
but the whole people accountable
uh for
uh what what what quickly became
apparent their disloyalty
to the president himself as well as to
his agenda so i mean that's who i am i
mean i'm the guy who who lasted the
whole five years i'm the i'm the the guy
who was in charge of trade manufacturing
policy um and and
regardless of any bad things people say
about me in my service in the white
house
um they'll say i was the guy who got
stuff done in trump time and so we got
we had a lot to talk about especially
with
everything so we're we're glad to have
you man i'm here brother all right we
got luke oh yeah we got a lot to get
into the u.s federal reserve is telling
people to eat soy to save money over
turkeys i mean i expected some
intervention not that kind of
intervention but holy freaking cow
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings and as you know i like being
ahead of the times and that's why today
i'm wearing a shirt that says gallane
maxwell did not bleep herself if you
want to know what that bleep is you can
go to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
also we're doing a black friday sale
with the promo code luke you could get
up to 15 off and we're doing it tonight
at midnight because screw the
corporations we're going to beat them at
their game we're going to do it before
anyone else tonight midnight black
friday sale uh 15 off or more with promo
code luke l-u-k-e hope you guys take
advantage of that and i will say uh
tofurkey not that bad hey
ian yeah delicious come on come on man
everyone's like i knew it
the truth is hey if you need to you can
pull that in if you want to leave he's
going to do a
t-shirt for the end trump time book can
you handle that maybe we'll we'll talk
and i bet we can all right we'll work
right now i got a deal for you
and it's just so freaky day this is like
this is like the marie antoinette of the
federal reserve yeah oh right yeah if
you can't eat turkey
right
why not
why not i am also here in the corner and
i just want to tell you peter you can
pull your mic up however this way yeah
super flexible damn baby here we go
i'm very excited to have you because i
really really appreciate i kind of
offend people because i'm like i really
appreciate the voice of the older
generations because i want to know oh i
am offended there we go
but i really want to know if things have
ever been this bad before because i feel
like we look at it and we're like this
is insane this is horrible and i'm like
is it really that bad
i guess we'll get into that during this
episode so yo i went through the 50s i
went through the 60s 70s 80s 90s no it's
never been this bad okay this is great
stewie generous this is great this is uh
just just just even like vietnam when
they were like manipulating people into
vietnam you it was no this is this is uh
that was all child's play compared to
what's going on now particularly from a
macroeconomic standpoint uh the problems
uh that we are facing now particularly
with the uncertainty of of uh
of when the pandemic may or may not end
it's interesting it's like in this intro
time book i talk about how
i was the guy in in early february think
about this i'm the guy in early february
who would write a dozen memos that would
jump start everything from the vaccine
development to the therapeutics like
people are taking now the remdessevier
the monoclonal antibodies things like
that testing ppe
um all of that that stuff
and um
one of the things i wrote in those early
memos was that the vaccine
would have to be supplemented by
therapeutics and the virus may well be
around for a long time because of its
ability to mutate and that's that's
that's the concern we face now so um
we got a lot more too i mean politics
china yeah the the inflation and stuff
like that
we'll get into all that stuff so make
sure before we uh before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only segment
where we get into the nitty-gritty dark
stuff that uh i think this one's gonna
be pretty bold because we've already
we've already talked about a lot of
stuff that's like youtube unfriendly and
so this is serious stuff having to do
with you know white house policy and you
know what's going on in china with
certain labs so you definitely want to
be a member not mrs when it'll be upon
11 or so pm but don't forget to like
this video subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends if you
really like it let's jump into uh the
first story i i hate to to jump right
back into like the news because we are
getting going but let's let's do this
because uh this is what we had we had
set up and i think this is uh this is
important as for the modern cultural
stuff so we have this story from the
independent
i chose the independent on purpose for
the source of this story saki links kyle
right now to proud boys after teenager
hits out at biden over white supremacist
defamation secretary notes written
outside with right-wing group excluded
from trial ah interesting the reason i
chose the independent is because this is
the outlet that claimed kyle rittenhouse
shot three black people i noticed that
which is not true
so of all of the outlets that would like
to make a comment on kyle rittenhouse
and defamation i thought this would be
the funniest one to use
the evidence says that peter ducey asked
whether or not mr biden would ever
apologize to mr rittenhouse for
suggesting online and on tv that he's a
white supremacist and saki responded the
video was meant to show how trump
actively encouraged white supremacists
and right-wing militia groups during his
presidency in her answer she referred to
a 2020 photo that showed written house
posing with a member of the proud boys
biden uh mr biden she added spoke to the
verdict last week he has obviously
condemned the hatred and division and
violence we've seen around the country
committed by groups like the proud boys
and groups that individual has posed in
photos with ducey's question did not
address the photo referenced by seki
blah blah blah i love it i love it i
love this idea that uh how many how many
conflicts are the proud boys involved in
you know a decent amount but have the
proud boys ever gone out actively
destroying neighborhoods setting fires
firebombing buildings or anything like
that um i oh wait wait wait
enrique tario pulled down a banner that
said black lives matter and they burned
in a street yep so that was that a
multi-racial uh person yeah by the way
and the organization is not a white
supremacist organization there's many
people of color within it and again it's
just absurd the logic that they're using
here okay let's use the same logic joe
biden took a picture with putin biden is
the president of russia now come on
that's ridiculous
he's a russian advocate exactly and and
kyle's words against the president
yesterday on that tucker carlson
interview were very pointed and i think
he's preparing for something bigger here
because he said he's accusing the
president of using malice and defamation
as you mentioned before actual malice
that's a legal phrase yeah
saying someone has malice you know in a
public setting like if you were like he
was maliciously smearing me or that
smear was you know his malice i mean
that just basically means like they're
mad at you they don't like you actual
malice is the legal is is the stan is
the legal standard by which you can sue
a public figure so here's what i think
happened i think ritanas was talking to
his lawyers
and he and and they said you know we
believe what biden said about you was
actual malice or maybe something that
effect and then kyle was like oh yeah in
the colloquial sense and then says it to
tucker
but it sounds like he's being you know
he's having these discussions now truth
be told you can call someone a white
supremacist and it is not defamation
it's not it's an opinion is it okay to
give
sake a compliment okay because of course
yeah because
after four years in the white house i
gotta hand it to her she lies she's
pretty much better than anybody we had
and i proposed um uh uh the the gensake
drinking game by the way
which was every time she lied uh you'd
have to take a drink uh a shot of sake
right you see
perfect and and yeah and
uh you know it'd be a short party
because everybody be passed out on the
floor within 30 minutes of the press
conference but it's really i mean the
the thing that strikes me
is that
um again you asked me kind of
perspective from from from my age and
things like that it's
we've we've abandoned all notion of any
kind of truth and now it's just simply a
battle of spin and narratives i mean
it's like you go you wake up in the
morning
and the the the cnn and mbas nbc people
are just
lazy they let the spin and narrative
come out of the new york times in the
washington post or whatever bullet
points the political candidates might be
sending and then off they run with it
and then you know we've got folks on the
other side of that but i mean it's just
just well
nbc
they're they're a lot worse than that so
during the trial and this nbc journalist
was trying to get
photographs the jury i mean this is
another po yeah it's like crazy like can
you imagine that like following an msnbc
reporter following a juror
to their home
your neighbors the jury bust yes
you'll never see morning joe wax
eloquently
okay well it's like lebron like these
people are so hypocritical like
lebron james on china right i mean look
it's like he lebron james will be the
first one to just just trash this
country upside the head i mean it's oh
this is a terrible place to live right
but but then you've got two million
people in concentration camps
in china and it's like uh can't talk
about that no no i can't no don't gotta
yes there was a boston celtics player
that wore a shoe depicting lebron uh
bending over to of course china bowing
down
to uh winnie the pooh yeah uh as he was
playing against lebron james yeah he's
also suspended for sucker punching uh
another player my hero my hero in the
nba is uh enis canner right that's him
yeah that's him
yeah because and and so he's protesting
now and guess what he's sitting on the
bench rather than playing you know this
this is not you know this is not cool
yeah there's another there's another nba
when colin kaepernick protested and he
eventually gets booed and nobody wants
to have him around i'm like you get
political you get into it you know yeah
yeah and they should i think we should
have these debates i think we we
shouldn't be afraid of politicizing
things kwame brown another former nba
star came out and he said surprisingly
kyle right in house acted in quote
self-defense he goes on to say that the
case was politicized for people to make
a lot of money promoting racism at the
expense of a teenager and a lot of
people were resonating with those points
after of course watching the trial that
was a live stream and presented a
different point of view that people were
denied if of course they were watching
the corporate media which many of them
didn't even put on the arguments that
the defense was even making during this
entire case which is crazy you know
what's crazy uh so the episode i
recorded a show with joe rogan last week
it went up yesterday and i was uh
reading some comments
and people were saying like you know i'm
watching this for i'm listening for 45
minutes and i swear this guy's just
making all this stuff up
it's because they live in the world of
cnn right and msnbc so when i sit there
and say something like cal rittenhouse
didn't cross state lines of the gun in
fact the d.a binger has charged dominic
black under the same statute because of
the straw purchase and i don't think
it's a straw purchase charge but they're
basically saying you provided a weapon
to a miner and then these people listen
to that and they're like that's not true
joy reid told me he cried colbert said
he crossed state lines i watch colbert
he's lying isn't he and i keep saying
fact check me google this take five
seconds just figure out we are telling
you the truth this is this is the
important thing i want to say about the
cal right now stuff
i hope everybody remembers when it came
to this show when it came to my my
morning show the the seven witnesses we
had we told you from the beginning it
was self-defense everything that came
out in the trial maybe maybe you're
someone who only realized by watching
the trial what was going on
watch our show you'll see we were never
lying to you we had the witnesses here
tell their stories some of these same
people have been on this show went on to
testify for the state and the defense in
that trial and sure enough the jury said
not guilty on all counts we had will
chamberlain here who said the gun
possession was legal the charges bunk
guess what the judge said actually
that's correct now if you were watching
cnn the whole time you got punked
we were honest with you the whole time
let me say one thing about cnn too
because um
john berman new day i
just happened to hear
the show in the morning
uh talking about the case tim and what
what just sickened me
was the tone in his voice
signaling that he wanted this 17 year
old person
convicted that was he was reporting the
quote news which was wrong and
contradictory to everything you just
said
but at the same time you could feel in
his the way he was reporting it was like
oh we we've got to get this guy
convicted i mean what what a
17-year-old kid
who
was was not guilty and found not guilty
by
by his peers
he's being condemned to
life imprisonment by the tone of that
voice
those people who listen to cnn
that they buy into that you see colbert
colbert said if that's not against the
law we should change the law
what they're really saying is for for
the past decade they have escalated
their violence and their riots and
they've gotten away with it and at this
point well now people are starting to
snap and i don't think it's a good thing
people showing up and you know
what happened in kenosha i don't think
is good in any way
but people are finally fed up we've seen
videos of people getting into fist
fights with antifa chasing them out well
now what's happening is these leftist
extremists are shocked and angry that oh
no now we're dealing with resistance
from people who don't want us burning
down their local communities now the
courts have said if you attack someone
and threaten great bodily harm we are
there's no precedent there's always been
self-defense well that offends the likes
of colbert no colbert when when when
they were burning down buildings when
they were fire bombing you know
government facilities when small towns
were getting looted and ransacked where
where was colby
[Music]
fundraising for these people to bail
them out so when this ruling comes in
they say the judge is biased snl does a
skit about it and they say there's white
supremacy blah blah blah they're just
angry that regular people have had
enough of their extremism it's a battle
of narratives that's what that's what
we've become in this
uh
society the the media has has gone into
the the traditional media has gone into
their respective corners and it's a
battle of opinion-driven
narratives not fact-based narratives and
i i'm
listening to you that actually you
actually had the witnesses on that blows
my mind that's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing yeah you know what i
realized today
when uh i was reading you know people
are commenting on rogan's podcast
there's actually two different political
compasses so when we say like you know
luke is like right libertarian or
whatever how people describe it i'm like
left leading libertarian and i don't
know where ian is he's in outer space
yeah pretty much i'm leslie libertarian
probably pro well probably but you're
probably more authoritarian than i am
well let me tell you let me test you
guys okay okay because
i always had trouble with the
libertarians in the administration
how do you guys feel about tariffs on
china
and uh well give me a little bit more
detail like uh so so with okay so
in the in trump time book there's a
great scene where i do go mono himano
with chris wallace on his sunday show oh
right and it's like we're in each
other's face and he goes
what what's the problem with china i go
and it just pops out of my head because
it's sunday right it's biblical i go to
seven deadly sins right and so i go okay
so here's the problem it's even get all
seven it's always it's always a chore
okay
okay you start with the intellectual
property theft to the tune of half a
trillion dollars a year you got forced
technology transfer
which is if you want to go and do
business in china
you got to hand over your technology
right totally unfair trade you've got
the the constant cyber hacking both of
personal individuals for their credit
card whatever but also businesses right
stealing their ip another form you've
got what's called dumping
which is sending
product below cost into markets as a way
of pushing the domestic producers out
and and grabbing hold of those markets
you have china's state-owned enterprises
up to five now right so these are the
these are the national champions they
send out with the with the full power of
the state to go out and do battle and
why why it's china building our subway
systems instead of american companies
um currency manipulation which is like
china lowers the value of their currency
which makes their exports here cheaper
in our our exports and them
more expensive so our trade deficit goes
up and then there's the seven
is the killing of americans
with deadly fentanyl and that's both a
health crisis
as well as an economic thing because a
lot of the people who die from fentanyl
are
working age
manufacturing blue-collar workers okay
so
um the the libertarian the traditional
libertarian view
is that well if china wants to sell us
cheap goods we should just
benefit from them
and what i'm going is no no no no it's
like
that's a form of economic aggression if
you take it as like a snapshot and you
go into walmart and stuff cheap that's
cool okay that's what but if you play it
like as a movie over time and all your
jobs go offshore
and your wages are driven down and
people go to the unemployment line and
workers wind up committing suicide
because they don't have jobs that's a
serious thing so i get back and
like in the in trump time book i
identify this this set of what i call
the wall street transactionalists like
mnuchin at treasury kudlow with the
national economic council mulvaney big
libertarian it's like i try to do like
buy american policies or china tariffs
and these guys freak out so i i'll throw
it back to you guys
libertarian do you do
tariffs on china to protect yourself
well there's two different libertarians
now you've got the mises caucus and
you've got the establishment you know
old-school type libertarians and they
disagree on a lot of things yeah so i
think the mises guys are like pro
borders right yeah very much so yeah
yeah so they're probably going to say we
have to protect american workers in
america and then i think their view is
more like within the area that we can
protect we have libertarian values and
views on how things are run yeah but we
recognize you know outside of the
borders so i i i don't know if that's
exactly their view but i would say my
view is is similar to that like i don't
want china ripping off american workers
using uh economic coercion and warfare
to try and destroy this country so
everything within the borders i believe
in you know very libertarian individual
liberties individual rights civil rights
etc and then when it comes to
international trade and stuff we must
protect the people in our you know
here's an interesting stat for you folks
our trade deficit with china is roughly
equivalent to the people's liberation
army defense budget
so
and and by the way uh it's tuesday and
friday is not just friday it is black
friday
and that's when everybody's going to be
going to the big box baby
walmart target whatever and a lot of
that stuff they're going to buy
uh when they pick up that made in china
stuff is actually going to be uh you
plow
plows into uh
swords pile shares into swords because
that stuff is that money or trade
deficit goes to fund all other weapons
and what drives me nuts is is you ask at
the beginning who i am it's like the way
i met donald trump i talked about the
interrupt time book because there was
some confusion there i wrote a trilogy
of china books right
2006 the coming china wars
2011 the death by china book and film
and then those were economic based and
then 2015 crouching tiger
which was the rise of the chinese
military so like in 2015 i write this
book and say yeah china's developing
these hypersonic missiles that can kill
us with nuclear weapons right okay so
that's like six years ago and so china
just a couple of weeks ago they fly a
hypersonic
plane around in low orbit which is
capable of bristling with weapons and
everybody's go wow wow that's surprising
oh my gosh
no it's not it's like in 2006
i predicted in the coming china wars
that china would create a global
pandemic because of the way they handled
the viruses and it was based on my
research of how sarge one came about my
point
here
is that china is an existential threat
you got you had joe biden say it's no no
it's just simply a competitor and part
of what i've been trying to do
and what president trump was absolutely
transformative about
was to raise people's awareness as they
used to say in the 60s about the the
threats
of of communist china the chinese
communist party coming after us and
they're coming after us and uh
there he is so what what
what are the tariffs do how will that
help so the way tariffs work um
if you if you if you
if
if you have a country like china
that is dumping product in or stealing
areas whatever the tariffs first and
foremost offset the advantage that
they've gotten from the unfair trade so
that's your first best right but what we
were also trying to do
with china
was to get them to the bargaining table
so in some sense the tariffs were a
penalty for things like intellectual
property theft or currency manipulation
so i it was fascinating the the first
chapter of the book i call it the red
wedding chapter uh in homage to game of
thrones but we're sitting we're sitting
there in the east swing and the
president's about to sign this this
skinny trade deal where we're supposed
to deal with this economic uh aggression
and um
it's like i'm fighting the wall street
transactionalist because all they were
concerned is trying to buy some more
soybeans or whatever they weren't
focused on the core problem but we had
this strategy
it was called dragging in a pot like
think about this it's like we knew that
there was be resistance to tariffs
initially among a certain segment of the
public but to get people to accept them
what we did but this was brilliant
president trump he got china to enter
into negotiations every time china did
something in those negotiations which
was unfair we'd raise the tariffs and
that allowed us over time to steadily
increase the tariffs to over 3 billion
100 billion dollars on tariffs and in a
second term i'll say this for the record
and i've talked many times with the
president about this we would have
completely raised tariffs on everything
to 100 and began to do what i believe
has to be done which is decouple from
communist china because every time china
makes another dollar
off
the united states or europe or whatever
it it's able to fuel both its military
machine but also the the war china is
conducting like through the so-called
belt and road initiation i don't know if
you guys have talked about that of
course yeah it's it's uh so it's
basically the colonization of africa
latin america
kazakhstan and everything like that i
mean they've they've got a strategy and
the advantage they have over us
as a democracy is that
we change governments
and officials every every four years
right and these guys that i would uh see
you i sat uh you know saka the g20
across from xi jinping and his married
band of apparatchiks same thing in
buenos aires uh many times i went to
beijing
these my point here is that these guys
across the table had been there for
years and they will be there for years
and i'll be gone and and instead now in
in biden land they've got a bunch of uh
uh appeasers and people who here's the
way they do this tim it's like like
there's money pots and honey pots okay
the honey pot is eric swalwell in
california right sleeping his way up and
down the coast with the chinese spies
i joked he had like stds like spy
transmitted diseases right that's that's
the honey pot right but the money pots
are much more insidious because what
china will do with government officials
is like they'll give them like trips to
beijing or they'll put them in the think
tank they'll give them grants at
universities and these people become
beholden to
uh the chinese and then they wind up
like jake sullivan as the national
security advisor right i mean this is
crazy stuff well there's well those well
they'll just do uh business dealings
with uh biden's sons and and agree with
your point when it comes to decoupling
especially from china's pharma industry
which the united states is heavily
reliant on but i think previously what
you were describing was globalization
instead of libertarianism because when
we look at what china is doing they're
they're they're treating china like a
conduit for a multinational corporate
takeover of the world and people are
using china as a slave factory to
produce the goods but this was all
started under henry kissinger who
literally took manufacturing jobs from
the united states
industrialized and then took all the
jobs to china and now china now has
taken a lot of work force a lot of
economic opportunities from the american
people and obviously if someone steals
from you that's not libertarianism there
should be consequences and you should
have a right to contract with who you
want to contract with and we shouldn't
be contracting with people who are
stealing from us so that libertarian
kind of idea still holds strong to me
but because of the multinational
corporations having so much power and
influence buying out the us government
we don't have libertarianism we don't
even have capitalism we have socialism
for the super rich which is orchestrated
by elites like kissinger
i take a really good short but nice shot
at henry yes he's he's he's he's you
know the dumbest one of the dumb smart
guys you meet along the way who's made
millions and millions and millions of
dollars from that the funny thing about
these corporations though the funny
thing about these corporations in
general electric is the poster child for
this all of these american corporations
who thought they could go over to china
offshore uh all the jobs and things like
that wound up getting destroyed over
there they got stripped of their
technology and they wound up having
competitors over there who were chinese
and then if you look like ge it's like
it hit its peak it was at its apex
then the moment it started to go over to
china that was the end of that
corporation now i i again i'm old enough
to remember when ge was the most
important and powerful corporation in
the world today it's like
china just took that so let's let's talk
about the uh the ramifications of the
binding administration's policies yeah
in one of the most ridiculous ways we
can
from the st louis fed on twitter they
say from the fred block
a thanksgiving dinner serving of poultry
costs 1.42 a soybean based dinner
serving with the same amount of calories
cost 66 cents and provides almost twice
twice as much protein now they're not
saying outright don't buy turkey but we
get what they're saying now hold on it
would not be
an establishment if the media did not
jump in and join in as well so google
search
don't buy turkeys and what do you see
well here's from mahoning matters
there's no turkey shortage but don't
wait to buy from the des moines register
why is there a turkey shortage then from
consumer reports there is no turkey
shortage followed by pita who tells you
not to eat turkey so uh the prices are
going up yeah we we went to uh we got a
fresh turkey we went to a farm and we
pre-ordered like they actually raised
the turkey from june and got all big and
then they
this past sunday uh and they told us
you can't get them in most places if you
want a turkey good luck and now that's
why the media is telling people hey hey
hey don't get mad you're not having
turkey for thanksgiving you don't want
turkey anyway right hey this soy stuff
is cheaper and better for you how about
that
now that
and people say to me that's not joe
biden's fault this is happening and i've
said over and over again i've done long
segments talking about why it is joe
biden's fault one of which is the
inflation gas prices speculation i can
get into it but let me ask you because
you know you're you're you're the
economics guy what what is it with with
the body administration that's resulting
in inflation high gas prices food
shortages
what is it
let me let me take you back to 2016 and
in the trump campaign and we had a
mantra
there uh the way we were going to grow
the economy and it was simple it was uh
tax cuts
not to benefit the corporations but but
simply to encourage them to bring jobs
on shore was deregulation to lower the
costs um and make us more globally
competitive it was
energy
independence
and and cheap energy which again is
makes us more competitive puts more
money in consumers pockets to help them
be able to buy more and increase their
wages and most of all it was
fair trade it was it was stopping the
the attacks not just by china on us but
india europe and everywhere else where
we had the lowest tariffs in the world
and everybody was taking advantage of us
now all of those tim are what we call
structural changes in the economy
designed to increase
growth and do it in a way where the the
productivity would increase and
therefore wage real wages would rise and
inflation would be held down that's the
that's the structural macroeconomic
approach to prosperity now if you think
about what went before that and what has
come after that that answers your
question before that
what what what the biden obama
administration did for eight years was
double
double the national debt from 10 to 20
trillion dollars think about that it
went from 10 trillion dollars to 20
trillion dollars that was pure what we
call in economics pure keynesian
stimulus designed to stimulate the
economy but it didn't work because they
didn't address the underlying structural
changes all we got was this i don't
remember the phrase the new normal this
was like slow growth and stagnant wages
okay so we come to trump things boom and
then biden takes over what has he done
he's reversed all four
points of the trump economic growth
compass right he wants to raise taxes
right he's slamming on more regulations
he's made just the worst mockery and
ruin uh of our energy policy and and now
we're begging the saudis uh to pump oil
uh i'll try a little comedy's always
hard but but here's a little comedy for
you uh it it at the football game
tailgates now before the games they're
eating caviar because it's cheaper than
cooking hot dogs with propane right
there's wings shortages yes
and there's wing shortages and then the
other the other thing is like my job at
the white house as i talk about the
interim time book was supply chains
right if you have your manufacturing
here
and
your supply chains will stay here those
are resilient if you send your factories
offshore here's the thing
supply chains follow them right and
therefore you have fragile supply chains
the best broken ones at worst and so
what's happening with the biden economy
right now is uh there's not enough
attention being paid to making it here
uh the the this is like i actually wrote
the order for the keystone pipeline when
we first got in it was the coolest thing
um it was one it happened early but it
was cool i i literally did this in 20
minutes it's probably the fastest
executive word ever written right but
but but biden undid that quicker right
the stroke of the pin and so go ahead
the keystone pipeline i think is the
best is the easiest way to explain to
people the rise in prices yeah so the
first thing you'll get from like usa
today is they'll say biden's policies
are not causing gas and prices to
increase and not causing inflation and
then when you when when when it comes to
the keystone pipeline they'll say the
pipeline wasn't set to deliver oil for
some time anyway so shutting it down had
no impact on the amount of energy we had
but what it did is that it signaled to
many investors and many companies the
supply chain for oil is not going to
meet
the requirements in the coming years
which which means
buy now because those prices are going
up speculators then start buying up in
fear that we won't have enough in the
future so the prices instantly start
spiking then when gas prices start
spiking the cost of everything goes up
right afterwards you got to drive to
work well i need more money for work
boss because the gas is too expensive
you want to get corn shipped to the
plant the plant to make whatever you got
to make in food the truck's got to spend
more for gas you got to spend more on
corn and guess what the the frackers we
are like the saudi arabia of frackers
pennsylvania whatever north dakota the
frackers
when these prices go up now are not
going to up production
to to to have that adjustment because
they don't believe they'll be allowed to
frack under the biden regime to your
point uh about signaling and that that's
a shrewd thing then because that's like
one of the core
uh principles in economics about
signaling theory somebody actually won
the nobel prize
back in in in talking about and that's
that's the problem we have and it's it's
just absurd
this is this is nuts i mean we're
sitting on on
literally with a saudi arabia of natural
gas and natural gas prices
are
through the friggin
roof that makes no sense and watching
joe biden beg not just to the saudis but
to the russians uh i mean opec is
basically okay here's a quiz let's see
see if you guys can get this right uh so
it's probably in so
biden has just released oil from the
strategic petroleum reserve how much how
many days or months of oil all right
lydia oh this one go baby because we use
18.9 billion barrels of gallon per day
right so it's gonna last us like two and
a half days yeah yeah boom yeah yeah to
your point signaling theory yeah that's
really gonna drive things down and what
you know what saudi did as soon as we
did that they all said it oh of course
they cut back production wow
they're strangling us out on purpose oh
well the saudis are like one of the
things um i regret during the trump
administration and this isn't in the
trump time book um was how the saudis
screwed our frackers um when they
started flooding the market um with with
oil yeah um and see there's a the
fracking thing there's a there's a
threshold right which is much
relatively higher than than pumping from
fields right the the traditional way the
south so so if you want to kill the
frackers you all you do is have to keep
the price of oil five bucks below that
threshold and the saudis did that
they've done that like two or three
times so real quick for people don't
know there's something called energy
returned on energy invested
and fracking for a long time didn't make
sense because the cost to actually frack
wasn't worth what you'd get out of it
but when energy prices reached a certain
threshold all of a sudden the cost stays
the same but the energy is now more
valuable they start fracking all of a
sudden we find ourselves as you
mentioned the saudi arabia fracking a
lot of left-wing activists really don't
like it
they really don't like it but it
ultimately helps us become
energy-independent
yeah and a lot of these arguments are
being made we need to stop domestic oil
production to help the environment when
in reality we're literally shipping it
from saudi arabia saudi arabia is doing
what's right for saudi arabia as of
course anyone would that's why they're
cutting their products i thought
according to gen sake saudi arabia had
their own like cone where all the carbon
stays over there right yeah of course
that's how that's exactly how it works
okay all right we got it we got a third
of the world we gotta have a hitter
donald trump also i criticized him
during his presidency because he was
very close with the saudis whether with
the weapons deal whether with
geopolitics they were hand in hand and i
believed he deserved a lot of criticism
for that personally myself but cnn had a
very interesting headline talking about
this kind of energy crisis recently they
had a headline that said quote why biden
can't do much to ease gas prices and a
couple days ago they had another article
that said oil prices are finally falling
thanks to china and joe biden literally
contradicting themselves just pushing
for the narrative they had another piece
today that was talking about the
problems with the inflation narrative
and they blamed everything on it's all
opec's problem it's all opec's fault no
it's not
well let's let's get let's get into the
specifics on the strategic oil thing we
have this story from timcast.com by an
administration to use strategic
petroleum reserve to lower gas prices
the white house will release 50 million
barrels of crude oil
this this is
it's
i i don't think that regular uh
americans who like lean democrat
understand signaling and how the the
actions of the administration
not not the hard actions but like what
people feel and see based on what's
happening we'll have an impact so i'll
give the example i just gave when biden
says we're shutting down keystone well
of course keystone wasn't transporting
oil so oil supply is unchanged but
people are predicting for the future if
we have x growth we're going to need x
percent oil increase and investing for
the future and not investing for the
future exactly so when biden shuts down
keystone and bans fracking on certain
lands all of a sudden people say whoa
we're not gonna have enough supply in
three years we better buy it now
everybody rushes everybody buys prices
skyrocket then what does biden do oh no
something i did is causing a spike in
prices let's dip into the u.s strategic
petroleum reserve which is for what
economic disasters and war and other
crises and start pulling out 50 million
barrels to get the prices down this is
another signal it's going to be a it's
an entropic failure it's a downward
spiral that's going to slowly spin more
and more chaos this move from biden is
going to cause more people to be like we
are in bad shape prices are probably
going to go up because of the action of
doing this the the w you mentioned the
50 million barrels of crude oil what two
and a half days
lydia got that right
she got the quiz right so biden thinks
putting out two and a half days worth of
petroleum is going to help ease prices
remember biden also by
bidenomics is kind of interesting it's
like he pushed he's pushing this latest
3.5 trillion dollar bill they want to
pass and he's saying that that that's
going to take inflation down
and pay for itself now in
in what world would that possibly happen
they have like the the a massive dose of
keynesian spending um which is look we
had a we had a two trillion dollar
bill that we were trying to get past
uh before the election uh at a time when
the economy uh
some help but but here's the difference
our focus
was on bringing our manufacturing home
we were going to spend most of that
money
as a way of promoting buy american
higher american and i think you
mentioned luke the medicines and things
like that
there's a whole chapter in the in trump
time book about this
executive award i wrote on what's called
essential medicines and medical
countermeasures and it was a buy
american order to to basically
bring home all of that stuff we need the
the pandemic was a wake-up call to us
majority of our medicines and uh also um
things that you need for medical
procedures are produced in china china
and and some of that stuff is in india
like if you take like like medicines uh
there's there's the fixed dosage form
which is the end product which which
which you get but but in between there's
the base chemicals and and then there's
the intermediate and
the base stuff is like really pollution
heavy um if you're not careful about it
and and since india and china are not
they dominate the market so we're kind
of stuck so when the pandemic hit like
india started it's like 80 countries 80
countries began rationing
either medicines or machines or both
um when that pandemic hit yeah it's like
it's like yeah it's kumbaya like it's
all reason together no no no no no
economic nationalism is what what
happens when when when the stuff hits
the fans the united states stole a plane
correcting me from monk from france that
had ppp in it uh do you remember that
that one i don't remember but i do have
a cool one i can tell you from the book
this was like let's call it the italian
swab job remember the movie italian job
when mark wahlberg okay so so i'm
sitting um i'm sitting in my office
um uh it's like a friday at late on a
friday afternoon just working my butt
off because the pandemic was like going
crazy i get a call from health and human
services and it's like
we got a million swabs stuck in the
italian alps because
they're getting northern italy's just
getting hit with a pandemic it's like
can you help right so it's like this was
the cool part of the job this was really
cool it was like all right so i call i
call the sit room the situation room
it's like the cool thing about the
situation room is like literally you
could track down anybody on the planet
within five minutes like if you need to
right it's like hey i need tim pool
get his ass on the phone yes sir yes sir
right
they'll find you you might be playing
your guitar or something don't want to
talk to me but they'll find you right
anyway on my phone anyway
anyway so so i i i get the pentagon to
uh agree to uh send a plane
from the factory right
um and and so while it's in the air
uh i realized that well we've got to get
the swabs to like six cities so i call
up the the uh ceo of fedex tracked him
down through the sit room fred smith
um and say hey fred look we got to get
these swabs out can you can you uh get
get us some of your planes he said yeah
once you
divert the plane to memphis we'll have
six planes waiting for you there so so
it's like from from the time i got the
call to the time we actually landed the
swabs in the six different cities like
72 hours it was that was pretty cool but
that's the kind of stuff stuff we were
doing um in the middle of the pandemic
one of the one of the other stories in
the in trump time book is is worth
sharing it's like the homicide
detectives in new york city were being
forced to go in and process
uh people who were this awful people who
who died a covet right that the homicide
because there wasn't enough front line
responders uh to do that right and so
they're freaking out because they don't
have enough uh equipment so
so the the chief of police uh emails the
white house and i
did monahan i pull it up and he goes you
know help sos here so i called um
these two two two really cool folks uh
at general uh dynamics
um
and and another company and um phoebe
novakovic in particular and say hey can
you get me some tyvek suits see these
are the these are like the the wrote you
know the kind of space age type suits
right and within 15 hours of getting
that email we had 4 000 tyvek suits
coming from all around the country
from these two defense contractors
that's that's the thing i was so proud
of this country when you saw
good corporations who would rise the
occasion and then i had to deal with
with bad ones as well like pfizer or
honeywell who just were in it for the
money tim i want to ask you about uh
what joe biden was doing a few key
points that i've i've brought up and you
know with your expertise having worked
in this uh worked in the white house and
all this stuff so i see joe biden uh
more regulations right
we see him say he wants the democrats in
general they want to raise wages they
want like you know higher minimum wage
and all that stuff and i'm all for
people getting paid i just don't believe
that you can just tell people to do it
it happens because there's a big machine
of economics but they want to raise
corporate taxes
they want to eliminate tariffs
and
and raise wages these three things
correct me if i'm wrong you end up with
a corporation the united states who says
okay we're just told by the body
administration and the democrats they
want our corporate taxes to go up five
percent so now we're going to lose x
dollars per year here in the united
states they also are saying we have to
pay more so now we're going to lose x
percent more in rising wages
but
they're getting rid of the tariffs
oh let's move the factory to china then
we'll pay people dirt we've got to pay
people dirt we're not going to yeah
exactly and so what what biden has done
is he's incentivized these companies to
leave and take american jobs yes and now
the funny thing is people say what what
is joe biden done it's not his fault
it's a pandemic and i'm like if you just
watch more it's probably what he's doing
yeah and then we look at this thing with
the oil it's like
when the ports got backed up
he announces we're gonna keep these
ports up and running 24 7 or whatever
you extend the hours and a lot of people
which didn't address the actual problem
that they couldn't do anything with the
empty shipping containers but of course
biden comes out says i'm going to do a
thing and then these people are
satisfied by it they're like oh well you
know biden's doing stuff and then
nothing changes things continue to get
worse at a certain point biden's
approval rating is in the gutter i mean
by all almost every polls got him in the
30s at this point independent voters
approval rate for independent voters 24
on civics he's in the gutter because
people are finally waking up and being
like yo i think these biden edmond
people are burning this country to the
ground you know but he's happy every
morning because he looks at the poll
numbers and kamala's below him that's
right yeah that's right
hey hey that's uh that's an adult
reference there
all the time
no no attention
yes yes yes
to be clear yeah it somewhere else
get the sensors out there no that's the
one who made that dirt that was
lit
yeah
you can't fault me
but tim your point is so so well taken
because look
again it's like confusing
structural problems with with with this
keynesian kind of approach thing it's
like here's the only way wages real
wages go up
it's if people's productivity increases
right if people's productivity increases
their real wages will go up if you
simply increase the minimum wage
at a time
where um
inflation is is going faster than any
rise you can do i mean workers aren't
going to be better off but if you also
like raise the corporate tax and you
have less investment as tim you point
out the jobs are going off to china stay
and stay in here
the productivity goes down as well so
it's like
the thing that
but he just doesn't understand basic
economics it's also massive money does
understand you said more sensible
economic principles in the last half
hour uh than any of the buying officials
have said since they got there i think
no yeah i think they definitely do
because if you look at what's been
happening who's been benefiting from
this u.s billionaires have gotten a 62
raise during the pandemic there's a
large transfer of wealth happening right
now from the very poor to the super rich
and who's benefiting who's calling the
shots well obviously the billionaires
are getting their way mom and pop shops
were destroyed during the pandemic while
of course walmart costco amazon all
those other big box stores were allowed
to be open as we were told two weeks to
slow the spread which was ridiculous we
all sacrificed but the other
corporations got to do whatever they
wanted to do you want to know what's
really amazing i was reading this op-ed
on the economy back in 2019 because the
economy was was was booming it was huge
i mean from my personal experience i
told the story when we were setting up
our first studio the lady at the
furniture store said 2019 was the best
year of my life
people were making money our contractor
who was doing work in the ed was like
the best year i've had so i'm reading
this op-ed and they said that all of
these things the leftists claim they
wanted four-day work weeks
higher wages paid vacation family leave
are happening thanks to capitalism and a
good economy the government need not
force it the machine is working the
policies are working and then what
happens
these leftists say we demand these
things
so when these things start happening
naturally they vote for joe biden who
reverses all of the things that trump
did and then end all of that really
great stuff and make a terrible economy
occur so
the the thing is
if you have good economic policy the
economy starts working starts it's
coming back the machine starts churning
you get lubricate the gears get them
going and when you have bad policy you
put gum in the works things slow down
and fall apart these leftists seem to
think i know people should be paid more
money i know we'll force people to pay
them more money as if that manifests
money or economic value or labor value
it doesn't yeah so when they came in
with the hammer to try and bash the
system which was already doing what they
wanted they broke it
yeah let me uh introduce a concept here
which i think would be useful to your
viewers
they call them service sector refugees
it's kind of at the heart of the
pandemic shock that we're facing that's
going to create stagflation which is
simultaneous inflation and slow growth
or recession
and and if you think about what the
pandemic has done it's it's been like a
neutron bomb to our major metropolitan
areas if you think about it it hit it
hits like the the core foundation of
major cities it's like the mass transit
it's the entertainment districts but
most of all it's a high-rise
office building right and so we've gone
from a world where in new york or dallas
or chicago
the high-rise buildings were at 90
percent occupancy rate or higher now
that down like like to
kamala's approval rating like 29 30
stuff like that now think about this
it's like the white collar folks to to
your point as to who's like winning in
the pandemic economy the white collar
folks are sitting out in the in the
burbs right commuting on their on their
little
ipads or
whatever they've got they're living
they're living okay right uh although
they might have to have tofu for for
turkey but that's another story but but
but those people who used to be part of
the ecostruxure of the cities the
janitors in the buildings
the trucks outside the the food trucks
the beauticians this and the other thing
they don't have anywhere to go and
moreover they don't have the skills
to transit so we've got this weird thing
tim where you got like
10 million or so people unemployed
and 10 million or so
job openings
that is weird and so i get back to the
central tenets of the trump
administration which is by american
higher american if we don't if we don't
build more of what we consume here those
service and train those help train those
people those service sector refugees are
simply uh
going to fade away into into oblivion um
and by the way i mean the millennials um
as as bannon loves to point out on the
war room uh
are turning into like modern day surfs
like you're not going to own a car
you're not going to own a home but you
know you can put that the virtual
reality thing on your head and your life
looks pretty good there for a while
where you stone out on exactly so maui
wowie i would love to ask you this
because in the beginning of trump's
presidency he was kind of battling with
the federal reserve he was clashing
heads with the federal reserve obviously
the federal reserve has been printing
money out of thin air that's why this
this kind of promotion of gmo monsanto
soybeans is absolutely ridiculous they
shouldn't be giving out nutritional
advice they should stop printing money
out of thin air but what was going on
with the trump administration with of
course them just literally printing
money during the pandemic and giving it
to all the hedge funds giving it to all
the wall street bankers giving them a
huge bailout well another shameless plug
for in trump time but there is a great
story about jerome powell in there and
it goes something like this
so um
it comes time to appoint a new fed
chairman it was either going to be janet
yellen give her another term or somebody
else right and so treasury secretary
steve mnuchin who i who i state flat out
in the in trump time book if he had
never come to the administration donald
trump would still be president wow this
guy did so breaking news here too this
guy did so much damage but one of the
things he did was he was the guy who
recommended jay powell get appointed
right and he did it under the assumption
because steve's a control freak he
thought he can control jay powell now
he did
jerome powell did something that that is
kind of contrary to what you just said
but i'll come back to you being right
what what we were doing with our four
points of that economic compass i
described earlier is we were able to
grow much more faster than the biden
obama regime
and do so without inflation okay the
only reason why the fed should raise
interest rates or tighten the money
supply is if there's any hint of
inflation what jerome powell did that
sob
he
ran contractionary monetary policy in
the middle of the beautiful trump boom
under the false assumption that somehow
there was going to be inflation so in
our time on our watch as i talked about
in the book he was too contractionary we
could have hit four percent growth
instead of three percent growth and
that's that's a that's a million job
difference okay so fast forward now
right it's like like
he is biden's guy now he's auditioning
for the job what does biden want biden
wants easy money to stimulate the
economy but what powell is doing is
contrary again to the facts in evidence
tim as he starts doing all the stuff
you're talking about in in terms of
biden undoing what trump did that's
provoking all manner of inflation you
add to that to pandemic shocks and by
and basically you go let me go back to
the 70s the 70s stagflation came about
because of profligate fiscal policy
check that box here with all the
congress is doing what arthur burns did
for nixon in monetary policy is the
chairman of the fed was to print money
and be too expansionary that's exactly
what jay powell's doing around check
that box and then what kicked off the
stagflation was the cost push food and
energy price shocks
of the 70s and we got the same thing
here and by the way you mentioned this
earlier tim and you were absolutely
right if energy prices go up guess what
food prices go up because things like
fertilizer which are energy driven go up
and by the way delivering the food and
other things go up and so
powell is he's a pox on this world and
the fact that we're going to see him for
another term
i mean
trump couldn't wait to get rid of that
guy we sat around scheming all the time
about how if we could take him out
before his term was up and whenever i
wanted to troll that friggin mnuchin in
the oval i'd look at the boss and say
boss who was that who wanted jay powell
at the fed
so
the other thing too is it's not just
inflation it's shrink flation where
products get smaller
but now we actually we have the story i
mean from timcast.com and it and i got
to tell you you know
this is typically not something i think
would be a big story but look at this
general mills to raise prices by 20
percent
20
yeah that is massive so you want to talk
about your kids having cereal in the
morning you know what really really
grinds my gears
when i've been saying over and over
again for the past several years like
you need to stand up for what you
believe in now you need to get out there
you need to advocate for for what you
what you want to see in this world
peaceful persuasive resourceful and i
get people saying like if i speak up at
my job then i'll lose my job and you
don't understand i got kids to feed
tell me now as the food shortages with
the price increases with the shrink
inflation and they're gonna they're
gonna raise the price your rice chex
your cheerios the kid wakes up for a
bowl of cereal and now you're wondering
why it's 20 more but not only that the
boxes are smaller and you're buying
twice as often and the food banks are
reporting that they're even having a
hard time feeding people because of the
inflation because of the supply chain
shortages so so peter i was going to ask
you
i'm always looking for the silver lining
here it's like the parents will need to
buy fewer diapers because they won't be
able to feed the kids
and by the way wait wait there's one
more point there you don't got to worry
about uh buying new clothes for your
kids when they when when they get bigger
yeah they're not going to grow as they
don't eat thank you very much we do have
an obesity crisis that's right but peter
how how bad does this get where where
does this oh oh this is this is what i'm
concerned about and again i get back to
lydia's question and point it's like
got a lot of miles on this bod i've
never seen it as bad this is like the
70s on steroids and so
so the way the 70s evolved that
literally as we came in from
it started with lyndon johnson in 68
with the refusal of choosing between the
vietnam war expenditures and the great
society okay there's this concept in
economics it's called guns versus butter
it's like you have to choose one or the
other in some combination in order to
maintain the budget it's like lbj was
that we're not gonna do it we're gonna
do both right so that's what that was
the fiscal stimulus that began
the whole whole process and and then so
it it's this whole stagnation didn't end
until 1981
and the way it ended was was brutal um
at in 1980 when reagan ran against
carter there was this thing called the
misery index it was
inflation rate plus unemployment and it
was 20
by the time that election rolled around
mortgage rates were like 13 and 15 i
mean this is like stuff that's not in
your the people who are viewing and
listening to the show can't even imagine
this because they've been they grew
they've grown up in an era of like two
three four percent mortgage rates no no
no no it's like they were like 12 and 15
percent now my parents tell me this yes
they're like when you were a little kid
it was like 12 yeah it's crazy stuff so
the way the way
it was fixed
uh and this is instructive was it was in
two ways paul volcker came along
um as federal reserve chairman never
confused paul volcker with jerome powell
and he induced the mother of all
recessions to ring inflationary
expectations out of the economy and the
only reason why that worked is because
reagan came along and did all the
structural kind of changes that we've
been talking about guys and and that
basically reset the economy and then we
went off on our 80s boom but but
but
that'll be a hard
trick to redo
because it requires both a smart fed
chairman and somebody as president who
understands kind of the structural
changes this could go on for a decade i
mean we're at 28 trillion i think is the
deficit right now he's looking at
printing three trillion more to put it
to 31. how do you with the amount of
having to pay
interest on that i don't see it ever
being able to come back from this at
this point where it's like other than
like um i don't know economic
uh default or something like we'll
default on the us dollar and create a
new currency or something this is like
pelosi's uh
hail mary
and big go brand into the world here
because if she gets away
with this latest
bill this last piece of the
multi-trillion dollar
pipe dream progressive socialist marxist
cut a puzzle because there's nothing in
that bill that will strengthen the
economy to be clear it's mostly a
redistribution and it's a subsidy to
china because they're all the ones that
are going to be providing electric
vehicle stuff okay let's be clear if
they are able to get this one across the
finish line
um
you're absolutely right that this this
will be with us
and and our children and our
grandchildren forever so there's a lot a
lot at stake here and it's like i think
right now
we're virtually assured
um of the republicans taking back the
house but it may be too late but the
other thing i'll say about that is like
right now i'm a trump guy right i'm a
mega guy i'm a deplorables guy right but
there is a there's a battle in the
republican party itself
uh between the the rhino
corporatist party of davos
republicans represented by mitch
mcconnell kevin mccarthy
liz cheney ben sass pat those folks mitt
romney versus the trumpers who really
want things like secure borders fair
trade buy american
manufacturing here and if we lose that
battle if we if we win the house
in in uh 22 and mcconnell and mccarthy
are still leaders we've lost the house
well so let me let me ask you um you
know you say you're making a guy
deplorable guy and all that stuff and uh
a lot of people are saying it's gonna be
a red tsunami because at this point i
think a lot of regular americans are
ready to vote for a ham sandwich over
the democrats but like you said if we
don't if if we don't primary a lot of
these establishment you know neocon
types then it's not it's all going to be
for nothing but there is the big
question you mentioned carter and reagan
the misery index reagan came in and
didn't against carter wasn't like a
major blowout election like he's just
swept ridiculously well i believe right
i think that was that election wasn't
that uh 84.
wasn't it was that no that was great
remember 80 okay it was 80 80 yeah well
so
so carter carter was in at 76. it was
kind of interesting
based on what you saw then and what's
happening now
first
is trump running
we've all heard that he is but you know
i'm interested in what you think and do
you think trump would landslide i mean
that figuratively internet like will he
have a they take it so literally
trump landslide is it it's it's a
figurative statement about trump winning
very very well do you think trump if he
does do you think he's going to run and
if he does do you think he'll just smash
through the election
um
look i i think that in 22 we have uh the
prospect of picking up
uh the largest amount of seats the
largest swing ever
that it will make the uh the gingrich
revolution
uh look quaint
uh by comparison but the one thing i
know in politics
is that um
short time frames
i mean 2024 is a long it turns a long
time wait everybody around here every
disabled are you assuming that it's
going to be biden or kamala i mean what
about gavin newsom they might even they
may even dust off cuomo or or who knows
what uh you know
matt mcconnedy
right might might uh might run or you
know my the one i think that okay let me
make a bold prediction here i'll be back
here in 2024. uh michelle obama yeah
that's what i've been saying i think my
money's on buddha judge i thought they'd
do michelle obama in 2020 because i
can't believe they tried biden oh yeah
yeah well they got it no but let's all
remember how biden got there because um
this was i take it you know you're more
of a bernie bro
not really no how dare you you just said
peter you just insulted me more than you
could ever imagine
you hurt my feelings you look like
you're never ricky you should have
killed me you should have worn the gads
didn't flash
were you involved politically in 2016.
um i don't like politics
were you involved he'd vote for ron paul
that's who he'd vote yeah okay if
anyone's fair enough yeah so we voted so
if you get a trump and hillary luke's
going to still vote for ron paul yeah
my point is simply that biden biden was
an accident of history engineered by the
by wall street and the big corporations
via
claiborne in south carolina let us
remember
that sanders was the front runner going
into south carolina yeah and he he said
something stupid
uh and uh
they were able to jiu jitsu
uh biden and he became the guy i mean
i've always thought that that they want
him in there just for a year and then
they put
um kamala in
thinking that kamala would perform
better than she has but at this point
this is why the michelle obama thing
it's like it's like you've got to run
something like that or oprah or you know
somebody else and i think i think if
michelle obama runs against trump it
will be a michelle obama landslide yes
figurative landslide oh speaking of
reagan beat carter 50 percent to 41 no
but what was the electoral vote
it was 489 to 49. wow 489 to 49. right
yeah yeah yeah major major
yeah yeah i was shorting cardigan
sweaters going into the election and
michelle
you brought up a good point with
michelle obama because i've been talking
about this for a long time this would
essentially ensure that barack obama
could have control of the white house
for more than just the eight years that
he was there in office uh four years
with of course biden because biden of
course talks to obama biden is helping
him with this presidency he would of
course have eight years probably with
michelle obama so we're talking about an
indefinite policy making by barack obama
which i i think would be absolutely
devastating for the country the thing
that that uh that that we've got to
solve in this country is the control of
the media right and because
uh that's how they they they maintain
power and this is again why i get back
to loving what you do tim and and this
diaspora
of um
libertarian conservative like truth to
power kinds of folks out there who are
dealing in facts evidence data receipts
signal not noise
it's just got to keep growing and i
think that you're seeing like for
example with fox news right it's it's a
cable everybody's plugged into cable and
the demographic is is way old right and
as that as that demographic fades away
literally
um
this will be your time because people
are no longer doing cable anymore they
have all these different ways of going
it but that'll be i mean if michelle
obama runs
in 2024 um
a lot whether she wins is going to be a
lot determined by how powerful cnn msnbc
the new york times the washington post
um and all those folks are google google
yeah let's not forget that twitter i
mean in uh
in in in the in trump time book i i i go
deeply into
uh the the the power of the social media
oligarchs in silicon valley and how how
it's just such a corrosive um element i
i remember like
there was a tactical glare this is this
isn't in the in trump-type book but it's
it's it's worth talking about it's like
um
zuckerberg came to the white house on a
couple of occasions
and it was kushner
who uh backed uh policy up from cracking
down
on uh on on the on the big technology
yeah yeah we we were we were there was
like a wing of us
in the white house
uh who wanted to do that and um as as so
often it was
on things like china or social media
jared and his naivete
thought he could romance zuckerberg and
meanwhile zuckerberg and if you know
this stat but he spent over a half
a billion dollars
uh in the six battleground states alone
which was more than what the trump
campaign spent so these guys you know
it's like when you it's kind of like
when on black friday when you buy
made in china you're you're basically
supporting their military
when you go on facebook or whatever and
participate in all that
you do enhance the power
of zuckerberg
uh of of dorsey at twitter and pichai at
google
and um
that would be fine if if section 230
were not in place and and
and they couldn't use their their uh
mechanisms now kushner made a lot of
very bad policies especially when it
came to saudi arabia negotiating for
them to get a better weapons deal but i
kind of wanted to ask you since you were
there on the ground um what do you think
anyone in the white house legitimately
believed in the two weeks to slow the
spread since i think we're on day 659 of
of that uh right now and and do you guys
have any regrets about warp speed
uh okay let's let's unpack that a little
bit let's let's talk about the lockdown
let's uh let's remember where we were
um
end of january uh
there were three people in the white
house who were taking the pandemic
seriously talk about this indian trump
time book it's it's was me the president
and robert o'brien the national security
adviser along with his deputy matt
potter okay and if you look at kind of
the history of this it wouldn't be till
march
it wouldn't be till march that people
began to take it seriously both you know
pelosi de blasio cuomo those folks it's
like hey everything's fine fouchy
everything's fine um and within the
white house itself you know i was
fighting minutes and i was fighting mark
short
mulvaney the chief of staff right so so
um
when it hit it's like i remember kudlow
it's like this is basic math right it's
like larry goes into a stab mean this
again is in the entrance book he goes we
got this under control everything's
minimal and i'm i'm there's only a few
cases and i'm going okay so so this is
kind of like basic math if you got
four cases today and and it's gonna
double then you got eight cases next day
it's like and then see how long is it
before you got a pandemic in the country
right this is what they didn't
understand so when this thing hit
we we we had our cupboards were bare
right for ppe right we've been left with
with no
gloves
whatever just not there
and we didn't know what we had and this
was so important it's like we didn't
know whether this looks like smallpox
with what they call the r naught of like
seven which means for every person who
gets infected seven more get infected or
whether it's more like the flu where
it's like an r not a one right so
so the lockdown was was a a knee-jerk
response to uh in the fog of war to
something we weren't sure were there so
you can't really honestly
monday morning quarterback that was that
was that
was that fun
hold on but this is a federal you're
talking about uh you're asking about a
federal question but the lockdowns were
state level
well trump trump even actually came out
later and said you know they shouldn't
do this but i can't control them yeah
pence with they stopped the spread was a
15 day kind of thing where they asked
everybody but here's the thing i was i
was one of the first and there's a new
york times article about this who yeah i
quickly realized okay so so here's
what's going to happen you got two
scenarios here one is like you lock lock
everybody down and you get okay so you
you slow
the the rate of infection okay but when
you're doing that some other things
happen right
you have a tremendous hit on the economy
and that we had the biggest recessionary
drop in our history in that so that's a
problem but the other part of the
problem is that people who are locked
down can't go to hospitals
to get kidney dialysis
cancer treatments breast biopsies
colonoscopies
and by the way if you lock people up
like rats in a cage
they're going to start taking more drugs
drinking more and eating more
and their health is going to deteriorate
so so
that's something that the fauciites
never
clearly understood they're knee-jerk
with and so so there became as we began
to realize that there became uh the idea
where no no no we've got to we've got to
learn how to open this up and then like
the best model here really
ex post is the sweden model sweden just
went for hurt immunity they didn't
master kids they they
they didn't shut down they just went for
it and right now they're having
relatively lower rates of infection than
the rest of europe because but but you i
mean we didn't know
yeah
a lot of that
at the time so but was it trump fouchy
or pence making these decisions
or was it a combination of them three
because a lot of people were bewildered
why fauci was still there for so long
yeah to be honest with you let me yeah
let me do this okay
this is me talking to the president this
is me
may or may not be telling the president
to fire falchion
okay on the cover of the yes
yes and i did tell the president to fire
falchi twice and once after my my
showdown in chapter two in the sit room
over the china travel ban which he was
adamantly opposed to and the president
sent me to argue there on behalf but to
your point luke here's the problem i had
and i i was i always felt like custard
like in the white house right so in this
case you had two forces in favor of
fouch you had the big four at the health
care agencies it was han at the fda you
had redfield at the cdc you had
collins at the nih and azar secretary of
health and human services they're all
going like fouchy's the best thing since
sliced bread got to keep them okay that
could have been overcome but the other
problem we had was the coward in the
chief of staff office
acting chief of staff mick mulvaney and
he and the press car were no no no can't
fire fouchy
too much blowback and i'm going like
churchill about hitler it's like no no
no no it's like you gotta strangle that
pouchy baby in the crib take the hit rip
the band-aid off do it but you know i
clearly i lost on that one and and and
fouchy
you know he's he's he's i can't charge
everything now but he was like
dramonstably trying to take out
president trump with what i called his
passive aggressive behavior and he was i
was the only guy who fought him luke
you'll go back and look at the history i
almost got fired once for it and and the
true story and and it's like i was right
every time i challenge them whether
whether it's on the traffic ban
especially in hindsight with him doing
the studies that we're going to be
talking about later in the in the bonus
section yeah uh in an area where we
could discuss this in a bigger deal but
oh yeah but there's there's a lot of
things that we could get into yeah
and uh thank you for providing such
insight into this because this is
leaving a lot of people asking what was
going on
here one other thing that i that i
emphasize in the in trump time book is
that pence never ever should have been
in charge of that task force yeah that
was a stupid scientific and political
decision because he was too close
to the oval office right what you needed
and as i argue in the in the trumptime
book it's like you wanted somebody who
was tough smart who could appeal to both
sides of the aisle and would deliver
this thing whiskey straight no chaser
because look like it's the the mel gibs
one of the mel gibson movies like men
will die you know people americans are
going to die right and there there's
going to be a lot of them or or less
dying but people are going to die no
matter what you do so that's not a
winning hand so you what you have to do
is you have to get your best people in
charge and and keep politics out of it
and that's we did not do that and and
and it gave fauchi in particular an
opportunity uh to manipulate public
opinion i mean every time his approval
rating went up the bosses went down you
know there's something wrong with that
there's something wrong with that he
struck me as like um old guard general
like a world war one general that was
still on staff when world war ii broke
out and you immediately realized like
you put him in charge and he makes a
blunder and you realize he's not able
he's not qualified to lead anymore
you've got to immediately remove him and
put in a young new general
and yeah i'm still waiting for that to
happen so do you think it was the
influence of all these four horsemen
that you detailed that kept fouchy in
there or do you think there was
something else it was that kept them in
i know it was it was a combination and
it was initially the four
horsemen literally of the pandemic right
in the healthcare bureaucracy but as
fauci
gained purchase in his perch there and
and his approval rating was high he had
what we got called a high q rating and
tv and things like that that's where the
mulvaney second act came in where
mulvaney was too too afraid uh to to
fire him and the press people were like
they were like they just like
they were like frozen in fear with the
idea of taking him on it's like no no no
no
so that
that you know that's that's that i mean
i hope i can provide you with the
background that's the fun part about the
trump time book it literally is the
definitive insider's account of what
happened there because i was there i
kept a journal um i most of the time i
was a participant sometimes i was
observer but a lot of these stories
people just don't understand as to what
happened and how it happened and like
for example pence's
chief of staff mark short i mean one of
the reasons why you do not want mike
pence running the task force is his
chief of staff mark short did not
believe there was a pandemic that he
thought this was just kind of the flu i
mean how can you get a task force moving
in trump time to deal with what this
what the crisis that we were facing if
the guy in charge de facto didn't
believe there was a problem and by the
way there's a funny story that's darkly
funny indian trump time book about this
guy mark chart i mean early on think
about this think about this short
decides to send pence out on air force
two
out to see the seattle area where the
pandemic just just was was developing
like people are dying left and right in
a nursing home and he thinks it's a good
idea for pence to go out there now you
might be thinking yeah of course we sent
our president or vice president out into
hurricane zones or tragedies or whatever
but but you don't do that in a pandemic
and here's why it's like it's not just
pence going out there it's it's all the
staff it's all secret service agent
agents it's the advanced staff and guess
what next day where are they they're
back at the white house right and you
have the golden opportunity
thank you communist china to wipe out
effectively the the the the top level of
government it was insane and that vice
president's office had the highest rate
of infection of any unit within the
white house because of mark short and
his stupidity who mark short made the
decision to send the vice president into
a pandemic hot zone yes
wow he's the chief of staff i mean look
look i look let me say this i i love
mike okay i had a great relationship
with him there's no there's no sour
grapes bitterness here one time there's
a great story in the in trump time book
about after i i did a tilt with jake
tapper one sunday right which was
particularly vitriolic as it always is
with tapper i go in the oval and we're
all standing around and mike does this
like wonderful impression of me
um during the debate like with my hand
gestures and everything like that it was
hilarious i had a really warm
relationship with him but when when mark
short took over as chief of staff midway
through the the the four years it was
like this iron curtain descended over
mike and you you could no longer speak
to him before that i would brief him
regularly he was open stuff he always
read the stuff he did mark short comes
along he just walls the guy off and for
all for the wrong all the wrong reasons
so that was all the more reason there's
a great again another story in the end
trump time book about how
i'm the guy
as the defense production act
coordinator i had like five warehouses
surrounded with fbi agents and bill barr
on my side to crack down on these sobs
who were price gouging we were ready to
raid them to send a strong signal to
anybody who was going to take advantage
of the pandemic that they were going to
suffer severe consequences guess what
mark short and the vice president's
counsel greg jacob prevented us from
doing that wow
yeah i was like
i was like
what are you guys doing why are you
doing this this is crazy bar i go to bar
i go bill it's like why can't we do this
and he goes well it's the vice
president's office it's like what what
can you do
well i called him it's like no this was
crazy so
um this guy
i'm into like
like homages and things like that so
like there's a lot of that in there but
this was a shakespearean tragedy and
there's a character in or
othello uh iago who for his own quote
peculiar ends betrays his principle
right and this was what mark short did
but mark short basically controlled
pence on the behalf of the koch network
which is which is the dark money network
of conservative money that that loves
certain aspects of the trump agenda
which is deregulation and tax cuts but
loathes lows secure borders and fair
trade because that prevents them from
offshoring yeah this was these these
were the guys in the midst mnuchin wall
street goldman sachs screwing everything
up mark short coke network larry kudlow
wall street these
it's very interesting the president
greatest president in modern history to
be clear but a lot of what he did he did
it in spite of who worked for him rather
than because of it let's go to super
chats if you haven't already get your
super chats in we'll take your your
questions smash the like button become a
member at timcast.com because we have
that members segment coming up around 11
or so pm but let's see what all of you
guys have to say
uh speaking to turkeys we have this from
the squid who says turkey sucks anyway
let's all have ham
and all the rest of the normal foods
turkey is bland and disgusting compared
to anything else you can have how dare
you get it i love turkey i love turkey
you gotta make it moist
moist dry turkey is a little look you
slice it and you make a sandwich and
it's delicious you gotta make sure it's
salted i'm not eating any i'm not eating
any bread and for the most part anymore
all the bread try the fryer you know so
you can you cook it right it tastes good
you cook it wrong it's bad you know what
i've learned i've learned when people
say stuff like broccoli sucks or spinach
sucks or turkey sucks you're just
cooking it wrong yeah it's that simple
salt
wars how many human beings died
over making food taste good east india
trading companies like peppercorn
they're like shooting
my uh my favorite expression from my
three years in the peace corps
was uh work hard rice delicious
yeah
rice delicious well meaning that if you
if you have you know if you if you work
work hard during the day that you're
dead yeah your food will taste good
lex friedman posted on instagram what we
think people from the 14th century would
be mind blown buying shows like iphones
what they'd really be mind blown by it
shows a bunch of spices on the shelf at
the grocery store
all right jay says soy turkey is a no-go
my mom has developed a soy and soy
extract allergy severe enough for her
throat to swell shut yikes man
keep your keep your mom safe and
hydrated well it's all frankenstein it's
all gmo just just get the real turkey we
got a 25 pound turkey because we went to
the farm and they asked us you know like
what are you looking for and i said i
want your biggest turkey and they're
like we'll get you the biggest one and i
was like okay and then we showed up and
they were like second biggest and i was
like you you i should but it's like it's
huge it's huge and after as they were
handing it to us i was like i don't know
if that will fit in the oven it's not
gonna fit and they were like just take
all the the racks out and just figure it
out and i'm like oh man
but it's going to take like 12 hours to
cook
and we are going to have one heck of a
turkey man
all right kyle miller says tim how long
until you get trump on
you know we've talked to people not
trump but people you know in trump's
circle and what we've basically been
told is there's absolutely no way trump
would sit down for two and a half hours
on a show like this a long time so it
will never happen oh it could happen we
go to mar-a-lago that's not this show
happening that's us doing like a special
sit down half an hour with trump yeah
like an hour there's no way we were told
this by multiple people that trump would
come here sit down hang out for a couple
hours and they were like if you would
get in there if you'd be like what bar
stool sports did i think like dave
portnoy did that interview with him
right
yeah you you'd show up you'd sit down
he'd eventually be like okay i think
we're out of time have a nice day thanks
for coming it's been a blast and you
know well i would like to point out if
you want to be president for four years
then you can sit down for two hours and
talk
trump doesn't need he's a busy man to
come here and do that to be president if
you have patience you have patience but
maybe one of our guests on the show will
one day be president oh i would doubt it
got a lot of people who are political a
lot of politicians and yeah hey you know
some of these people are pretty young
like late late 20s maybe in 30 years
yeah you know be like wow i can't
believe that guy's on my show nice
running for president i also bet we
could get trump talking and continue
talking and i think it would go on a
little bit longer than expected and i
think it would be a lot of fun and it
would be a very important conversation
so someone mentioned like uh
there was a way you if you watch the
media interviews trump's done to get him
going and not stop
was to say he did something wrong or
something like that and then have them
just get into heavy details
perfect yeah i don't know does that
makes you think say that
there's a reason why i survived five
years for the president right
i would love to have that conversation i
no no see the thing about trump is that
i'm pretty sure if you luke were like
what's up with the deal with saudi
arabia he'd be like listen i'll tell you
what happens and he just go off yeah
good we want that we need that we want
to get a perspective that the mainstream
media didn't ask him the mainstream
media was going off on lunatic
assertions that had had no basis in
reality if there was some actual
constructive criticism i think he would
want to listen to it and want to have a
conversation about it i think so
personally yeah and about
industrialization yeah cheeseburger says
tim please can we just ignore the
corporate media now uh colbert et cetera
let's just do our own thing and ignore
the evil doers um tim cast is a
corporation tim cast is a corporation
but corporate media has a reference to
like conglomerates not a small like you
know 30 percent company we're not even
as big as daily wire but uh you know the
thing about colbert is
what's happening is you have a lot of
regular people waking up they go to the
store and a turkey which cost 20 bucks
last year is 50 bucks this year and
they're like whoa
50 bucks if they can get one there's a
lot of a lot of areas where you get
these high profile blue checks they're
tweeting out pictures like look at all
these turkeys and then you've got middle
america places where people have no
turkeys and they're like what are you
what is this like no one the the
craziness about what the media is doing
right now
is they're constantly just potemkin
supermarketing everything's going on
potemkin gas prices they're saying look
how cheap it is here look at all the
wonderful abundance here and then
regular people are sitting in there like
you know empty living room with an empty
fridge just being like what is going on
but it keeps a lot of people in those
areas under under wraps let's not forget
the jimmy carter cardigan sweater moment
this what was that i wasn't alive oh you
don't know about this yeah
so
[Laughter]
so
let me take you back to the 70s um
because my first job
was in the department of energy and my
job was to figure out how to get us off
foreign oil because we never imagined we
could do what we did under president
trump which has become energy
independence so what happened to him
back in those days to start the
stagflation
was opec cartel
basically through the saudis did an
embargo
on the american people and they they had
two
separate
oil embargoes where the price of oil
went from you know like 30 bucks a
hundred bucks overnight there were large
gas lines i don't know if you you've
ever seen pictures of that
and and at the same time we were having
food price shocks so
so carter
carter
gets elected because of the misery
associated with what was happening
and his solution is not to drill more
oil or
crack down on the saudis or whatever it
was like wear more cardigan sweaters and
freeze in your home right right
and so he gave this famous speech right
where he's sitting and the lights are
like dark and he's got like he's like
look he's guy's like a former navy
nuclear guy he's got no sense of like
look at this beautiful studio here if
he'd done it in this studio he might
have got away with it and had like like
christmas like gears on his on on the
sweater but no it was like a really dark
vision people go i don't want to live in
that america and so i mean here we go
it's like the tofu thanksgiving i don't
want to live in that america yeah so
this could be
biden's cardigan sweating momentum you
heard it here first on the tim poole
show i would love to see three days
before thanksgiving joe biden comes out
tomorrow the day before thanksgiving
because news you know don't eat turkeys
people are complaining he says listen
tofurkey is delicious
americans are strong they don't need
turkeys
eat your soy america and then everyone's
going to be like approval rating just
drops to 0.5 although he might go up a
little bit in iowa right
where they make the
all right junior v says i cannot wait to
see how the mainstream media spins the
black friday mob robberies of stores and
innocent shoppers
oh yeah did you see what's happening in
san francisco with the people like 25
cars pull up 80 people run into was it a
nordstrom or something
and then
in union square at like a louis vuitton
they're raiding buildings because
they're getting away with it it's close
to home my uh my cvs uh which is like
right beside the building where i live
in in dc
just closed because of uh all the
vandalism and uh and the theft at the
thing so it's like best best buy is
taking a hit and their stock took a
major hit because of the mass robberies
yeah it's so i'll tell you this you know
what i see happen i just think the
country's collapsing
there is that we're in a 50 50 country
right now and um the progressives have
been in the ascendancy
and everything they're doing undermines
us economically socially culturally and
boy are people fed up with that in the
flyover country and main street and
um
again to lydia's point i look i've never
never seen nothing like this like during
the vietnam war okay
um
the kinds of demonstrations that
happened in washington
was was massive it's like stuff that
happened and now with the blm whatever
around the white house
that was mild compared to what you saw
in dc but but it was in terms of size or
violence in terms of size but but that's
it the violence
back in the 60s they were huge crowds
but
there there was not the kind of violence
that you're seeing so you have that that
kind of difference and then um you got
the 70s stagflation we're going to
really experience
that again you know the 80s was
relatively prosperous the 90s were
some of the bet you know that was like
the boom of the decade you know it's
like so this is we're we're we're way
outside and pandemic remember the last
pandemic we had was 1918 yeah with the
flu and this one look one of the things
i get one of the
things in the in trump time book is was
my quest
uh to write an executive order which
would have gotten to the bottom of of
how the virus came came to america right
and we've done presidential commissions
for pearl harbor the kennedy
assassination the bp oil spill
i just want to say that as the guy who
was like at the center of this
if i had been able to get the original
genome of the virus
from communist china at the time
we could have uh
got a vaccine
that would have been more sophisticated
and quicker
than we did so it's not insignificant
that we we weren't able to do that so we
we i don't think we get to the end of
the pandemic until we understand the
beginning of it and i think that's a
fair question uh that everybody should
have on their mind
all right we're gonna read this one from
red rum axe he says uk is advertising
crickets and cheeseburgers on public
transport i saw a huge poster on the
tube today could not believe my eyes now
i will say um we we cooked a cricket
bread remember ian yes and it was not
good no cricket bread not the best it
was cricket flower crickets ground up
into powder it has to be croissant boys
yeah we should have made our crickets
nothing here so i will not everybody
knows that
and it doesn't have anything in it
it doesn't have anything in it that
functions like bread does it have as
much protein as tofu
probably more
but the problem is it's got an
so if done right i would say it was not
good
it was food and i will tell you this um
if if like i went in the kitchen and
there was nothing and there's cricket
bread i'd eat it and i would not be
upset yeah we made it in a bread maker
but for sure if you made like a bake a
no-bake bread like uh with some sugar or
some salt you know you can make it taste
really really is there the underlying
question of why
why do we do it
yeah well so when the cicadas came out
it's like should i go to the moon or
well they're advertising eating cricket
they're telling everybody isis yeah
who's doing that uh in the uk they got
advertising
the media was saying all last year eat
cicadas and i'm like
please don't eat bugs there was a
restaurant there was a restaurant in
leesburg virginia
that was that was picking cicadas off
the wall off their in their backyard and
serving it to people and the health
department said you can't take bugs off
the ground and sell it to people
and they were they were and cnn was like
oh look at all the people eating cicadas
yeah it's it's you combine the proteins
and guinness stout and the crickets and
somehow in england it tastes better
that's well do you know you know that's
what you were missing yeah you know the
story or preferably you drink like six
bottles against out before you eat the
crickets and then you know you know the
scenarios about somebody you know three
cards cricket's delicious yeah you guys
know the story about how about guinness
yeah and and there so i read this in one
of those trivia books and it it it may
not be true but
there's this book and it said like you
know the story of guinness
they they used to have the big vats
where they make the whatever you call
them where they make the booze right
yeah make the beer
and when sanitation became a thing
around the industrial revolution they
cleaned everything out
when they started brewing the beer again
people noticed it didn't taste as good
something was missing and so they didn't
understand what was missing so they you
know checked and they were like
everything's the same but what they
didn't realize and again this may not be
true i just read the book i'm saying
it's very careful i don't want to assume
uh what happened was rats would climb
into the vats to drink it and then drown
and die and sink to the bottom
and then decay
so they replaced it with fish oil and
they brought the flavor back or whatever
okay i don't know if that's true again i
just i read it in a weird you are a
lovely shade of green for the holidays
who needs a christmas tree when you've
got lydia strong yeah right thank you
here we go joshua says tim don't worry
about the turkey shortage you can still
buy a rotisserie chicken at costco for
4.99 that's right i mean hey how about
instead of a turkey everybody gets a
rotisserie chicken
chicken why is it it's half the size it
was last year yeah yeah right they're
getting smaller well we we got our own
chickens but we're not going to eat them
we got about 15 chickens those five dog
chickens are probably modified and
injected i don't think they are the same
day
you have is that what you we have
ten laying hens well we have i think
seven laying hens and then we have three
um pullets they're they're or actually
they may be yeah they're pull it's
they're not quite adult yet and then
we've got uh uh one rooster
and then uh
three no four other cockroaches do they
wake you up in the morning they wake up
the rooster does yeah although i'm
starting to sleep through it i talked to
my mom last night i got these chokers
for the roosters where you put them
around their neck and then they go oh
so they don't really scream very much
she was like that's so cruel yeah we
can't it reinforced i don't wanna i'd
rather just tough it out i read too many
horror stories where like what happens
they have heart attacks the roosters
will try and like i'm gonna freak out
i'm gonna let the rooster do his thing
we'll move him to the farm eventually i
think is the plan so yeah we're gonna be
moving uh the black stars and dorothy to
uh the new place so they can have their
own little you know chicken chicken
chicken chicken heaven but we got the
most luxurious chicken coop it's chicken
city it's massive these chickens are
free range one percent of chickens man
protected they got this hanging water
thing they got their food chicken races
out there or anything what was that no
no but we're actually in the process of
setting up chicken city live show
so we're going to have cameras
all over you guys it's it's massive it's
massive it's underneath this like house
and uh it's it's really huge so we're
gonna put cameras everywhere and they're
all gonna live stream and the cameras
will rotate periodically and then people
will be able to go to the live stream 24
7 to watch the chickens do their chicken
thing so i got an idea for you okay so
like like
elevate the chickens up
and then have a uh a pond beneath it
right
and you can do the aquaponics oh with
fish you think so right well that's how
they do it yeah it's rough though
mosquitoes in the summer so you gotta
add a bunch of stuff
because the droppings from the chicken
yeah like a fertilizer yeah yeah yeah
aquaponics yeah yeah
well chickens sure do poop that's one
thing we know for sure they are they are
poopy birds
all right raymond g stanley jr says
peter sir if we get that second term
you're predicting can we save our
military it's uh it's cr is crap too far
ingrained to still have a strong force
uh versus china now crap stands for
critical race applied principles i see
so we're seeing all that wokeness in the
military
so um
let me let me reflect on uh one of my
experiences from the intrum time book
within the context of mad dog mattis
okay
this was this was um
remember the old saying in reagan like
personnel is policy right meaning that
who you hire is like what what your
outcome is in the white house and stuff
like that so so mattis
mattis gets in there is is
a four-star general he's adamantly
opposed
uh to all of the trade policies we want
to do he's adamantly opposed to taking
on china he wants to be an
accommodationist
and and he uh spends all of his time
disobeying the chain of command like no
matter what president trump the
commander-in-chief would tell this guy
he would not follow those orders now
think about that this guy's a four-star
general if anybody should understand the
importance of chain of command it should
be
general mattis now why do i say this in
answer to your questions like this is
the problem we have in the military it's
not unlike the other bureaucracies where
there's a culture that's been adopted
where the pentagon seems to be
independent
of the leadership and from i'm really
surprised that this critical race theory
has has been able to metastasize so
quickly in the pentagon because
it must have been going on during the
trump administration we just didn't see
it happening so that's that has to be on
our watch but um what the pentagon needs
to be focused on is one thing military
readiness that's it
military readiness i mean don't you
think it's very important for the
military to also be ready to you know
talk about each other's feelings
well you know what if what if there's a
soldier oh look you got a guy in basic
training
but
there's a guy in basic right you know
he's 18 he's enlisted
he's crawling through the mud yeah and
then that's crying yeah and shouldn't
should the drill sergeant and everyone
soldier no snuggle snuggle puddle
cuddle puddle you know he's crying
everyone's got a hug and then they can
go and watch you know cartoons i heard
safe spaces are bulletproof right oh no
i i'm look i'm deeply concerned about
the military we were we were able to
significantly increase the military
budget and kind of get it back towards
the trajectory it needed to be
uh but
we're woefully unprepared
for what is likely to be our
leading military threat which is china i
mean you're seeing the whole doctrine of
of peace through strength reagan trump
right i mean think about this we come in
and trump trump everybody understands
he's a tough sob right so what happens
immediately north korea missiles they
stop flying those things right iran kind
of backs off from all the crap it's
doing we're able to put tariffs on china
without it going going berserk right but
as soon as trump's gone it's like like
what is china doing yeah are we watching
it's like they're they're
they're they're throwing uh air aircraft
across taiwanese space they're they're
threatening
alaska and hawaii yeah they're getting
our faces yeah they're getting right in
our faces they're calling by the way the
the summit that just happened i don't
know if you watched that but that that
term like when she
jinping called joe biden his quote old
friend that was good oh
oh man that is some kind of insult in
china baby no no it was because uh i
think saki was asked
peter ducey said something like you know
biden and his old friend she and then
they were like i assure you biden is not
friends oh and so xi jinping was then
like my old friend joe biden is like uh
you know that's an insult yeah for sure
murphy tries diy says tim wouldn't
answer a call from the situation room
because he would think it's a call for
extending his car's warranty actually
that's incorrect i don't answer calls to
extend my car warranty
out of fear it may actually be the
situation room
the other way around well hey by the way
tim if you didn't answer that phone we'd
come find you that's great no that's
fine by me
and if the trump administration was
looking for you it wouldn't be bad news
okay if the buying administration comes
to fallen that's
that's a totally different uh
my phone rings i don't care what it says
i don't answer it yeah you know because
i don't do that by the way on a personal
note just just so you understand it's
like how how washington works it's like
right now i'm um i'm under attack by
this subcommittee that claiborne runs
uh they're trying to get me to to
testify
yeah yeah yeah but there's a good story
here because um
it's like
um
they they sent him to keep sending me
these emails as they say and i get an
email a couple days ago and they say
look uh here's your subpoena uh if you
tell us that you got it uh then we'll
consider it served i say yeah sure right
i got it right so what happens the very
next day right at 10 in the morning um
and i'll actually show you the the the
video of it because i took an iphone of
it sure enough a sheriff shows up
with a subpoena come knocking on you
yeah these people are trying to do like
intimidate you and like that woman in
colorado who who they're branding the
domestic terrorists and the fbi sends
like the six agents to and and like
tears their apartment up or house up to
find what whatever it is there that's
not there that they're looking for i
mean this is well this is this is a big
concern this is part of the problem i'm
seeing it's like um
the department of justice under merrick
garland has become
essentially a jack boot
and the fbi
as an extension of that i'm sure that's
most of the agents in there do not want
to do that but i would love to see some
more resistance within the fbi and i'm
calling on that right now to kind of
like hey
slow down a little bit because
you know mothers who are worried about
their kids shouldn't be
searched have faced search words but
anyway that was an interesting story
it's a bummer because you know i grew up
with the x-files fbi and they were cool
yeah they were cool even even like
outside of you know mulder and scully
when they had the actual fbi there's
like there's like
hey we're tracking down a murderer and
we're gonna we're gonna help protect
people but now it's like it's so cool
well see i grew up with the j edgar i
know i know
so i know how it can go bad but you know
it's like it seemed like things were
were going
pretty good but this whole you know this
whole
russia gate thing uh it's been broken
wide open out shown to be a hoax
bulldorms like indicting people and
things like that but that went on like
for four years
for four years the five it was before
the before the trump admission
administration even started yeah and it
was still going on up until durham
started making these moves now rachel
maddow's finally forced to be like oh i
was you know lying the whole time oh she
was just really dumb i'll put it that
way
it's it's strange how you know when the
initial reports were coming out like my
my content was all like hey you know
we'll look at it and we'll see what's
what they say and you know i don't know
enough about what's going on to make a
judgment but we'll see what the
investigation reveals and then once it
came out like there was no collusion it
was all a hoax i was like okay we're
done with this right no no they didn't
let it go they keep they keep doubling
down triple them down on i mean there's
a i was just watching uh
comey rule on netflix right and it the
whole
thing is misinformation and
disinformation because it sincerely kind
of presents the story as if the steele
dossier
were were true
right and you go through the whole thing
and and and if you look at it's like the
the prologue but to the interrupt time
book i call the roshamone election i
don't know if you guys uh or lydia you
ever seen rashamon okay so this is a
cool movie let me let me let me pimp a
movie here for a minute right the the
greatest
director in in japan's history is uh
akira kurosawa right he did he was the
guy who did the original seven samurai
right which which they made a western
version of things like that but he did a
movie called rashamon and it was
basically a violent crime scene through
the eyes of multiple individuals right
and and every person who saw it had a
different version of what what the
events are like and i feel like that's
we're in this this ramon world right now
with the fbi and and cnn and this that
and the other thing and i it's like
here's the thing let me just say this
four years in the white house
i saw so many stories
that were quoted anonymous sources that
were just flat out wrong just flat out
wrong and i i kept thinking to myself if
i know they're wrong because i'm inside
what about the people who are reading
this who aren't inside that's right
right and and i got this rule at
woodward uh indian trump time book i
take him down okay because
um there's a story about me in the
situation room and i report how the
events happen
woodward reports the same events with a
totally different spin right based on
two anonymous sources and my rule with
people like woodward are two anonymous
sources do not equal a fact right and
that's the way
journalism has gone to and and well here
here's how they do it they'll say uh a
source close to nancy pelosi's office
reveals that she's planning to impeach
you know joe biden or something yeah and
then it turns out the person close to
her office is the homeless guy sleeping
out back behind her office well hold on
they're telling the truth he is close to
her office
and he's out in the back going like
werewolves are taking over the white
house and nancy pelosi will impeach
biden you wait and see and they're like
write it down and publish would you be
surprised to know that that a number of
reporters knew that i was going to be
subpoenaed before i did
not surprise you of course now think
about that think about that
think about that who how did they find
out
well come on people are leaking they
link it yeah the classified information
yeah don't those agencies work with the
mainstream media i want to read a couple
more super chats before we go to the
member segment but uh cause i noticed a
lot of people are saying spatchcock the
turkey yes i hear good things
okay so spatchcocking is where you cut
it open and you butterfly it you lay it
flat and it helps it cook more evenly
and that's supposed to be super good i
like it i like the traditional 12-hour
bake yeah but you're gonna have to put
it at a diagonal in the oven yeah well
people are saying smoke it they're
saying spatchcock and then put it in
smoker sounds amazing i'll tell you this
um
the best brisket i've ever had in texas
when we were in texas
literally out of the seven days we were
there i had one day where i didn't eat
brisket
my gut is still recovering we had a
little bit of brisket today i was like
prepared to be disappointed it was chain
food brisket it was not good all right
so uh
we'll do one more here this is important
catherine mcgrath says did jimmy carter
really get attacked by a giant rabbit
ah i have no freaking idea all right all
right all right yeah so uh here's what
we're gonna do um we're gonna go to the
members segment where we're gonna talk
about the deep dark secrets so make sure
you go to timcast.com become a member
you can don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel you can
follow us basically everywhere at tim
cast irl follow us on instagram you can
like our videos and help them spread you
can follow me personally at tim cast and
of course i think you've got something
navarro unchained okay let's rock
but you got a book i think you mentioned
i think i have the in trump time book
here yes
i like that photo much much by the way a
little breaking news for you tomorrow
morning um press release is going out
where i'm actually recommending another
book
um to buy uh at the holidays in
conjunction with this it's called the
real anthony fauci by bobby kennedy jr
and this is my account of fouchy during
the year of the plague and kennedy comes
at it from the previous decades where
fauci was there and
i think that as a gift for the holidays
by the time you get to the end of those
two books you will have a very different
view of fouchy if you still think you're
santa claus i think oh yeah i know where
you guys are
[Laughter]
i heard i heard great things about that
bobby kennedy book i'm excited to read
your book thank you so much for coming
on i got a million other questions i
want to ask you uh but i'll save it for
another time are you a burning brother
that hurt my feelings i'm hurt
you noticed like when i said that that
for the rest of the show he didn't speak
to me at all
i had some questions i i got a lot more
well you know but in fact in fact the
the the the eyelids of the
zane t-shirt the the the master came off
briefly when i said that it was probably
yeah it was shocking her eyes popped up
it was it was surprising but we got a
lot more to get into i'm excited to talk
let me let me let me pimp your t-shirts
too to make up to it no worries no
go to wherever you're supposed to well
thank you i appreciate that uh i do
other videos on of course a different
youtube channel but i have more private
intimate crazy discussions on
lukeuncensored.com i released an
important video today i'm going to be
releasing another one tomorrow about how
to talk to your loved ones in a
pragmatic way especially when you're
going to be meeting with them sitting
down with them luckily if if you are
very uh blessed to have a turkey you
will be eating one and it's an important
opportunity to raise important issues
i'm going to be talking about that all
on luke uncensored.com hope to see some
of you guys there it's great to meet you
man this is thanks for coming and this
is awesome releasing the info this is
deep stuff i'm looking forward to going
deeper i'm ian
let's get real and you can follow me at
ian crossland.net if you want to get in
touch with all my socials thanks for
coming and i just wanted to say before i
go that the rashomon effect is where the
two people are looking at a six slash a
nine and they can't figure out which is
which so there's actually an effect
named i i think it's inspired by this
movie that came out in 1950 thank you
very much for coming peter had a
wonderful time i'm loving this wisdom
from these older generations you guys
may follow me on twitter at
sarahpatchlids we will see you all at
timcast.com in the members only segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you